in this lesson we're going to talk about
polynomial long division so this is
something that's tested on the s80 and
it shows up in a couple of different
forms so let's go through a couple
examples once you pause the video see if
you can do these problems on your own
and then we'll go through them together
so the first one it says the expression
for X minus 5 divided by X plus 2 is
equivalent to a B C or D so what do you
think for that one go ahead and try and
do that one on your own we'll go through
it together now if you want to do this
one using polynomial long division what
you can do is you can say where X minus
5 is being divided by X plus 2 so we're
trying to see how many times as X plus
to go into 4x minus 5 so what you do is
you look at this first term here and
this first term here and you say how
many times is X go into 4x well it goes
in for time and what you do then is you
take the floor you distributed to both
of these terms so that's going to be 4x
plus 8 then you're going to subtract but
what a lot of students like to do is
change a science to the opposite and add
so that's going to give you negative 13
because he's canceled and then because
this is a lower degree than X to the
first this is your remainder this is
going to be minus 13 / x + 2 kind of
like if you had how many times is six
going to 20 it goes in three times with
two left over what do you do with this
the two you say three and 26 rights you
take the remainder over the divisor and
of course you can reduce this so for the
first one it looks like the best answer
here is going to be letters C okay now
some students you may have learned you
know how to do the synthetic division
and if you're dividing by a linear
factor like this meaning just like X
plus something or X minus something you
can use the synthetic division so i'll
just mention that real quick here if
that's something that you want to do and
you remember from your math class so
what you would do is you bring down this
for you've multiplying the diagonal and
then you dad straight down and this was
originally actually the first so this
ends of going down to buy one degrees
that's X to the zero so this ends up
being four and this is your remainder
and you put the remainder over the
divisor and you get the same result but
here in this particular lesson I'm just
showing you the long division because
you're not always going to be dividing
I you know X plus something or X minus
something it might be a little more
complicated like this one that we're
going to do next so it's good to just
know the long division technique as well
so let's look at this one here it says
which is equivalent to five x squared
minus 9x all divided by 5x plus 1 so go
ahead and pause the video see which one
of these options here would be best and
we'll go through it together okay so
same idea we're going to see how many
times 5x plus 1 goes into 5x squared
minus 9x plus 0 right because there's
not really a constant here so how many
times is 5x going to 5x squared x times
right because x x 5 x gives us 5x
squared x times 1 gives us x we're going
to subtract or you can change the signs
to the opposite and add that's what a
lot of students like to do this is going
to be negative 10x plus 0 and then how
many times is 5x going to negative 10x
well that's going to be negative 2 times
if we distribute we get negative 10x
negative 2 times 1 is negative to change
the signs to the opposite and add 2 is
our remainder because two is the lower
degrees in five acts right so that's
going to be our remainder over our
divisor so the best answer here is going
to be letter D so polynomial long
division and important concept to
understand for the s80 go ahead and
review the lesson if you need to and
i'll see you in the next lesson